foreign
welcome to a wolf language design review
about the
well Consolidated kernel configurator
how to connect to kernels from your
front end
um okay
so Roman take it away
yes so at the moment we have
two mechanisms for configuring kernels
there is the
kernel configuration options which
manages there
kernels that the front end knows about
and then there is the
parallel kernel configuration parallel
and
sorry that's in the preferences
so now this used to be a small
old-fashioned
uh kernel configuration panel in here
but that was no longer maintainable with
the new kind of configuration based
system so at the moment the
configuration is so command line or
service Discovery only and so I wanted
to reintroduce a graphical way of
configuring kernels and that should work
for all types of kernels including
front-end evaluators
so the proposal is to have a new tab
here with kernel configuration and then
we can probably get to it of the
parallel tab because the only thing
that's left in the parent temp will be
that General preferences which we can
program let me make a comment at the
same time here that internet and mail
thing and it turns out it's the orphan
Alpha connection you know that's kind of
crazy
I mean
I probably should say
I don't know it's it's um and where's
the cloud connectivity
I mean okay
this was supposed to be part of the
system Services project which somehow
you know is dead on the vine can anybody
to talk to anybody else's comment on
system Services
I can comment on system services but
first the project is definitely
hibernating we have a system or a
language API for setting and getting
these preferences but there's but
there's little value in that because we
don't have any
you know a compartment Based Services at
the moment right we we do have uh well
male was supposed to be the first one
male was the first one and we could add
it for mail but mail already has uh you
know configuration ability right and we
don't need to introduce systems but how
do we do geo servers
well at the moment there's no Geo server
other than our own
how would they deal with it well if they
had a privacy I'm not exactly sure
there's probably some sort of dollar Geo
service there is that they can set but
at the moment I'm told by the Geo server
folks that that is not like the that our
Geo server is highly specialized today
and at the moment you know I think
geoserver is a ways off as an example
the next most Labs example pack with
service and we have it designed for how
we could do packlet servers with the
services API but I don't think we need
to
go into that position here right all
right fine fine
kind of yeah okay I mean I kind of think
just in terms of refactoring this I
think it's incredibly obscure
that you know I think we could have more
things than John might want to comment
on this we could have more things on the
left column here like mail separated
from cloud separated from Wolfram Alpha
and so on
rather than putting together things
which will not be seen as conceptually
similar
I I mean I'm fine with adding more tabs
uh that's not a problem
uh as far as cloud is concerned I mean
the problem is any anything interesting
one might want to do with the cloud is
just not implemented in the front end
yet so there is nothing to configure
here
I see other than kernel variables
right
okay
um but but those kernel variables you
know they're how they influence
front-end behavior is uh you know
um it's a bit tricky and I I wouldn't
want to expose that right
yeah fun all right let's understand what
the goal is
I mean
to me
one of things drives me crazy
is
you know
I want to be running something in
parallel on for example a very common
thing for me
is run it in parallel but I want it on
machines that are not my own desktop
machine I want it on the other machines
that I have
sometimes I wanted also on my desktop
machine because it's quite kind of a
beefy machine
sometimes I'd like to pull in
um you know something in a in AWS for
example
I would like some way where I can easily
pick out those things and say parallel
evaluate across that particular
collection
is this going to give me that yes I mean
that workflow is part of the of the of
the design that okay all right let's
let's dive into the design okay so what
what this new design wheel support is
editing kernel configurations in a
graphical way in addition which we
already have for the for which we've had
for like 35 years 40 for the front end
kernels yes right
but we want to modernize especially the
SSH support for the fountain currents
anyway to make use of
that connection tunneling and so on so
it's a good good and and I use the same
functionality for parallelism anyway so
so that will be a lot of shared code
okay so let me make another comment
um sometimes
um
you know somebody sends me a notebook
and they left it connected to their
kernel which is a kernel I do not have
okay
and so then when I try and run it it
complains
might it not be a good idea
when you open a notebook that is
connected to a kernel that you don't
have
that it puts up a dialogue saying that
and says do you want to realign this to
just be using the default kernel
so that would be a kind of a modern more
modern notebook kernel
item here no no what I'm saying is you
understand the scenario somebody yeah I
I understand it and uh not a dialogue
but yes and you know something in a doc
style or something it's you know it's
not let's not do dialogues but but I get
your point
and it's a reasonable one I mean and if
you hit shift enter
and it says and it brings up the thing
saying that kernel doesn't exist there's
got to be some way maybe in that
dialogue of pressing a button that says
just reset this notebook to use my
default kernel yeah well I think the uh
well there are two choices here uh one
is uh uh you know that we can just use
your default kernel uh but we probably
don't want to switch the notebook to
use the default kernel unless we tell
the user that's what we're doing because
then that fact gets saved into the
notebook
Fair Point okay fine so uh I mean it
needs a little bit of us
I don't think we need to design it here
I can figure this out and I'm I'm not
worried about coming up with a sensible
solution okay fine
onward
okay so the other parts of this new
stuff will be choosing which kernels to
use for parallelism for front-end for
you know locally evaluate and all of
this is backed by persistence so you
could store a list of kernels in your
cloud account then easily access that's
nice so that okay so so just so I
understand there'll be an easy way
to give a name to a group of kernels so
that I can just say parallel evaluate
and then give the name is that correct
name for a group of kernels is not yet
in this proposal but it is a very good
idea because at the moment I just have
to select the sets of kernels but it
should be possible to give them a name
yes right but so in particular then in
the kernel
I can just say parallel evaluate onto
that group of of kernels right I mean
the
yes at the moment the way it works is
you define a variable whose value is a
list of kernels and you can initialize
that variable persistently so I don't
think we need an extra layer for names
of kernels no I don't agree I don't
agree I'm sorry I don't agree let me
tell you my use case again okay
you know when I'm doing a big country
computation
if it's overnight for example I wanted
to use all my machines including my
desktop machines yes okay if it's during
the day when I'm using my desktop
machine I don't want it to use my
desktop machine I wanted to use the non
you know my other machines
you see what I'm saying yes yes so I
want to be able to have two names there
that that I can use
um
I also might want or or similarly you
might want a group you're willing to pay
money for or a group you're not willing
to pay money for that seems a reasonable
scenario as well yes exactly I mean I
would love to have something which is
which is named to be a thing which is
some AWS kernel
that I know I'm paying money for
um another case which maybe we've
covered separately
is the representative from every
computer
yes that already exists okay
okay all right let's move on okay so
there is not much in terms of new
symbols but there is a lot of ux UI
design so let me show you a functional
prototype so I've obviously not spent
any time making it beautiful because the
people well who's here who is going to
deal with the beautification
do we have somebody from graphic design
or ux here
if that's what we're primarily talking
about
I will go snag somebody
okay
okay let's see the quote is it requires
the Prototype currently and there's also
some extra code which I have not put
into the repository because that's the
thing where most likely UI design will
make changes so okay okay fine just show
us what we need to look at okay so the
First new functionality would be that
kernel editor so if you have
currently you create kernel
configurations with with option settings
and now there is somewhere this this is
a symbol that we introduced a couple of
years ago kernel configuration yes yes
that is not new so editor whatever its
name will be is the new thing and so
this will bring up a data to even
user interface for all the changeable
public properties and that depends
obviously on the Kernel type this is for
a local kernel so it will have the
append in-out name all right what's our
model for this what other things do we
have that bring up I mean I have to
admit I don't think we've been like like
molecule draw for example is an example
like this
am I making sense
John can you talk about that
you know what things do we have not
understanding the connection to molecule
draw at all and frankly I haven't
actually used molecule profile much so
okay unfortunately but I mean I'm what
it does is you've got a thing in your
session and it brings up a dialogue
separately
like this
so I'm saying I mean this is the thing
where you are you know where the
workflow is you start with something it
brings up a dialogue you change the
thing and it goes back again
what what else do we have that does that
oh that's actually
I mean input does that in some sense yes
I mean the I I thought about this and so
what what I came up with uh is
where is so it
so what do yes we have we have two
functions that prompt for input and with
block and return the thing yeah then we
have three more that insert
that bring up many special characters
insert color insert file path
but these are really the only ones
but also front-end things they're not
things which are initiated
we have file browsers that correct Could
you type it in and see what it does
so do we have five rows
no
what do we call um
insert right we have to insert files no
no we have a there's a kernel function
which brings up a file browser and I
should use it uh
uh system dialog inputs
um
oh yeah but there's also a control
systems
file this one open no no no no no system
dialogue input just type a quote the
string file open camel case
what is it doing it's not a good sign
um
is it on another monitor Maybe
it should have popped open the open
dialog and then waits for the results
that's why that that's why it's hanging
is because it's waiting for the results
so there is oh there it is yes okay
there it is
so okay
okay yes so these are the kind of things
we have we have very few of those
and so
do we need or want one for specifically
for kernels I mean the nice thing would
be you could do something like locally
valued and then you could have that
thing it would prompt you for for a
kernel and you could then change the
some of the properties of that kernel
and I would like to use
another version
okay and then it would immediately use
that kernel and run the evaluation on it
but that would be a possible use case
for this for this function well I mean I
think it should be called kernel
configuration edit or something like
that
or kernel I mean I don't know it's going
to bring up
it brings up the kernel configuration
editor yes so
but I don't think it should be called
editor I think it should be called edit
it's an action
well yeah I mean how do we call these
things that actually bring up something
and wait for
well we don't have very many of them the
block kind of configuration dialogue
yeah there's uh uh message dialogue and
there's another one of the dialogues say
forget which it is
um
I don't know let's keep going
we have a few dialogues like that
well what do you think this should be
called John
um
I think edits
is a reasonable choice so it will be
kernel configuration edit
yeah why not kernel configuration
dialogue
because it's obscure because I mean the
fact is it's an edit isn't it I mean
it's going to return
also not all dialogues
um
not all things with the name dialogue
follow that pattern
uh create dialogue is uh
um well maybe all the things the the
form noun dialogue do that yeah okay but
although why is this not an alternative
would be you see the configure kernel
configuration blob but maybe you press a
button on that and it brings up the
editor
but then you first have to put something
on the screen where you can push the
button yeah include this articular case
and the idea of the other proposal here
is that if there's no argument then it
will prompt you for the type of Kernel
and it will then give you a chance to to
edit to to end all the information for
that new car
so maybe we can occur a configuration
edit this is probably a good name
okay provisionally yes okay let's keep
going and then one small detail that
requires some care of the UI I just
wanted to to show you uh what the idea
is at the moment when you enter an
option for a new kind of configuration
that is wrong because this is not a
valid host name then when done like this
it gives you the expected message but in
the kernel editor I follow the idea of
something you see a lot in web forms for
example if I hear enter something that
is not a host name then at the moment I
just have this this pop-up that it's not
one of our forms
you didn't custom write this form right
I mean this is just one of our forms
this is just uh this this is input
string or input input input field and
the rest is just some glue around it I
mean but why isn't it using a form
function
well isn't it just using our standard
form punch because it has a standard
method for dealing with oh you know I
mean that's a whole giant system so I
should look at prone functions yes but
but did you custom write this as a
it should just be exactly this and and
then we know it works on all platforms
and we know it has good error behavior
and so on
because it has a mechanism if you enter
something that's the wrong thing
and then we also don't have to redesign
the you know we don't need a lot of
design because it's already been
um
okay I look at that
then as soon as possible hand it over to
uh to UI designs so they can design it
right right but okay all right fine okay
now we have one more terminology
decisions configuration edit
yes
that name is not sitting that well with
me I just want to make that clear I'm
not really a fan of that name but it's
the best I can think of right now can we
see the dialogue again please
mm-hmm
what the hell is Fe kernel arguments
yeah what kind of a name is that
yes I mean I I've
no I need to change those I mean the
problem is it gets a bit too so the idea
is that the
arguments that are supplied to when
launching that kernel that they depend
on the use case so the front-end kernel
will have different arguments from the
remote evaluate kernel from the parallel
sub kernels
these are basically keys in an
association true or not true
now these are these are elements that
will go onto the command line with which
you launch I know but but in terms of
the kernel configuration function inside
that piece yes these are also okay so
then then those keys can just be strings
that are quite long
yes okay yes makes sense and I mean here
I think we've many many times we have
sort of
you know
englishified
things for the purpose of a dialogue
am I making sense so instead of having a
camel cased
you know remote evaluation kernel
arguments or something
we just write that out as separate words
I'm not sure what the right thing to do
is but but but you know either it's just
a long name there remote evaluation
whatever it is I mean some of these have
have tool tips with with some more
explanation of what they do
but clearly these these are a bit
critics yes
I'm sorry Stephen did you say that we've
used camelcase or we
no I'm saying that we have examples
where underneath it's a camel case
variable but in the description in a
dialogue or something else
okay okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I thought
you were making statements about the
underlying
Association okay no
yeah
no I should I should simply add another
data item that would be the display name
for these for these options
yeah I think so but I mean also like to
talk tips here but you know in our name
that's really cryptic it's like is it
no I mean we should make these things
more explicit there's nothing wrong
include and out labels I haven't I
haven't spent time on the design of the
okay but I mean
it uses the wall option names okay fine
I understand but those should be changed
I mean to be yes those should be changed
so it's like include in-out names and
things like that yes
um
kernel command string I don't know is it
is it dollar command like that that's
the thing from Dollar command line right
which one's the kernel command that's
just the first that's just the binary
without the I I'm aware I'm aware but
it's a
maybe that's the right name for it
um
uh
okay I mean I don't know it exists so
that but these These are these down here
are new ones so they can very easily be
changed okay it's kind of upsetting that
you didn't use the form function
mechanism because it's a big mechanism
and it allows you to do all kinds of
things with contingent pieces of forms
like here you could check things in I
mean presumably you don't need all of
those different kinds of arguments if
the usage wasn't there
right if you remove parallel
subcanalysis usage
it doesn't but it should but it could
with form functions okay yes now I have
never used form functions so that's the
reason
I talked about using form functions to
mark this up but his goal is to mark
this up in the quickest way he could and
so if whatever straight notebook
programming was his choice but uh but
fine okay all right
so
all right so then somewhere there is a
manifest of what this did so is that in
the kernel configuration blob or what
in other words what like the comment
where do I see the comment
yes I mean the comment is something I
just introduced I haven't
any usage for it but it could be for you
to annotate because this is a kernel
that costs that many dollars per hour
yeah I understand that but where is it
going to show up no I mean some of that
will show up in the I mean these will
also these these are just the ones
friends from the current version so
there's a Chooser presumably for I mean
the menus should only have in them
if I'm not mistaken
yes I mean the the I mean here at the
moment like notebooks girl so that's
that's how this yes and so that name is
what what is at the moment it's
underused but the sorry that I wanted to
show you this uh this is the name and so
this is what you should make
I'm trying to understand
the front end obviously needs in the
front-end dialogue system you know
front-end menu system something that
says where to connect this front end for
its kernel for Notebook kernels
okay when it comes to remote evaluation
and parallel evaluation it is a mere
courtesy that the front end would
provide any way to configure that
am I making sense yes I mean the front
end is not involved in that no I
understand that but but in the past
has the founder okay are you intending
that the front end as a courtesy
provides the ability to GUI specify
those
uh
you know the things for parallel kernels
and so on
yes I mean this is part of what we're
talking about today okay fine we're in
the menus of the front end will that
appear
well is that appearing in the one kernel
configuration options and that's going
to handle both evaluations no the kernel
configuration options these I mean this
this will just lead to the new tab in
the system preferences
okay and then parallel kernel and
parallel we'll go away that will also
lead to the same the same pattern what
about parallel kernel status that needs
to be worked I mean it it worked well
but it's not scalable for larger number
of kernels it's hope I mean I it just
kills my yeah I mean it is if if you
enable remote monitoring then if you
have 100 kernels then for every
evaluation it will do 100 requests and
so it does just doesn't scale
is there any way out of that I mean we
should probably just a little bit then I
mean one thing one thing to do is do for
example first thing to to group The
kernels by machine and so you have just
one summary information for all the for
all the kernels in the machine and then
I mean it's really up to you to decide
do you need fine-grained uh Telemetry
for the kernels but then you have to
accept the fact that it's slow or do you
just need
okay
property status the master kernel can
figure out without querying the sub
colors okay and that's what the Roman
Roman I'll tell you what I need what I
want okay if this kernel configuration
status worked properly
I would like it very much
very useful if you're doing a you know
if you're doing a computation
so a very common type of thing I'm doing
is various kinds of search type
computations where there might be a
straggler
you know and I'd like to be able to see
that kind of thing yes I mean those I
mean that two thing this is the general
one and these on the right hand side
these are the expensive ones which which
wear with any more colors no I know the
other thing would be an extension of the
current progress dialogue so it would be
something if you do a parallel map it
would give you information specifically
about what the kernels are doing
with regards to the progress of that
parallel map so it would have to know
what operation
it's doing to give you more meaningful
feedback
well
I I don't understand I mean as far as
I'm concerned
it would be very useful to just see I've
got a hundred kernels out there 25 of
them are still busy 75 of them are
finished
so if all it did was when it finishes it
puts up a flag and says I'm finished and
that would show up in the status box in
other words if it hasn't had the I'm
finished flag it just says it's busy
can find that out without even querying
the subturners so that Queen
icon here should be
like if I
okay fine fine fine fine fine fine then
then we can see that local ones are the
the the cheap ones and the remote ones
are the expensive ones
okay obviously okay hold on hold on hold
on
you're telling me that there is a
default configuration of this dialogue
that would actually just work for my
Hundred kernels and not burn the
computers all up right you would have to
disable the collection of the
performance data but that's not showing
me the most important thing yes yes so
we needed something in between so we
need as much uh
performance data that can be collected
without pinging yes right because that's
what we need that's the default here
okay that I can do that yes
I mean it was never an issue with 10
years ago 20 years ago when you had four
clowns or so but now it is yes
um
okay so I mean let's make that happen I
mean it should be rather straightforward
you just have something by the default
so so then that is a meaningful
dialogue and it doesn't just you know
Crash and Burn
okay yes okay so there's one
small
uh
terminology F you have seen before these
three terms lunch or devaluation
parallel sub current event Arena these
are the three supported use cases for
curlers
and what are the functions that do that
one shot evaluation isn't that little
remote evaluate local evaluate and in
the future it will also support
session kernels so you can keep kernel
open and run it not one shot is it yes
so so that name will be wrong in the
future and they are kind of long and I'm
wondering whether we just shoot them
short to have evaluation kernels
parallel kernels and format I don't
believe in that I don't believe in that
I think it's extremely obscure
but because hard enough for people to
understand is will only be used in the
context of a kernel so I don't think we
need
we need more context I I understand that
I understand that but but the fact is
well okay hold on let me think about
this
maybe front end should be called
notebook
yes that's what
what day out right it's the notebooks
curler yes
um
what do other people think about this
it's a bit obscure
um
foreign
local evaluate
um
what's the conceptual difference between
a remote evaluate and a parallel
evaluate
the point with remote evaluate is it's a
single evaluation on a single kernel yes
parallel is a
correlated evaluation on many kernels
yes and you cannot
address individual kernels out of these
so it's you don't even address the
current at all you say parallel parallel
map then it does its thing
um
I mean single evaluation which goes with
your one shot anybody else got a
suggestion here
what specific phrases are we trying to
replace or well the things we've just
been talking about right evaluation I
don't like one shot though no no no no
it's not right so the question is what
is right so this supports local evaluate
and
remote evaluate but I don't know how you
build a session how do you build a
session for the moment you cannot get
but that's another thing that we need to
design we need to find the proper term
for starting a session we have well
we've got about external session yeah
that's external evaluate that's an
external evaluate realm a session
a session not this not a single
evaluation yes but but easy but external
evaluate look look normally external
evaluate
is the thing for other languages and we
couldn't apply that to our language as
well and call it an external evaluation
or something
yeah that's one possibility so I just
wonder whether it's the best one or
whether we should have something
a bit more
I mean
no no look look look look look look if
what we call it is
if we say
this is what's confusing we have local
evaluate we have remote evaluate
okay let me ask a question I've got many
cores on my local machine
do I get to address one of them as a
local evaluate uh you know in other
words just like for remote evaluate or
do I just address a machine do I address
it anymore because the course I know
they I mean okay some Modern processors
have these extra slow calls in addition
to the normal ones but
I mean days I mean the same is a
question for parallel evaluation
sometimes when you really want to
dedicate the machine to computation it
makes sense to pin each kernel process
to a particular core but there are there
are operating system means to do that
but that is below the level of our
language
okay but but I'm trying to understand
in the case where
I mean
if you want a local evaluate which is
session based
what on Earth is that going to look like
and we have a pattern which is start
external session
yes
so at the moment what happens when you
do a local or remote evaluate it
launches a kernel then does the
evaluation closest to curl so what I
want to do is to have separate function
for launching a kernel then you could
use that launch kernel which will look
almost I I get it again it should be
called new status argument too okay so
I'm suggesting something I suggest we
call it start evaluation session
okay and that's the thing that
that then returns some kind of session
object which you can then think that
just returns a kernel object okay but
then you can feed that to remote
evaluation what's the difference then
between local evaluate and remote
evaluate
do you want the difference currently is
the default
kernel they use so you could have you
have a D4 kernel to use for local
evaluate and you have one that points to
your favorite machine
that's that's the only difference it's
it's really the same function
so start evaluate session would take a
kernel configuration as argument and
with terms config and returns a kernel
object
as result which represents a running
kernel and you can then use that
for
no clothing won't evaluate
yeah yes it's a shame that we have
uh that we're distinguishing now between
local and remote
maybe we just need a sub-evaluate or
something
um
evaluate this unfortunately no no we
wouldn't want it anyway
because it's a different it's a
it's like an independent evaluate yes
you know what I'm saying it's a it's a
um uh it's not a parallel evaluate
because parallel evaluate means many
things in parallel
um could external evaluate be overloaded
to provide this or is it completely
different
no it's almost the same it's just that
we have these
start external session and it returns an
external session of it and the shame is
that we have this sort of you know the
separate names and sessions
string based but
I mean it it implies serialization right
which we don't need
wait no the in the the mechanism by
which valuation occurs is completely up
to the particular okay implementation
for that language
um
so that line that usage could be
extended to have a session as the first
argument and any
language expression as a second argument
sorry I I was not paying attention for a
second could you I mean yeah thinking
about whether we could be abuse
externally evaluate to to WTS local or
Remote device yeah I don't think so
because I think it's got an expression
as a second argument rather than a
command it's a mess yes I don't think we
should do that I think we've got more
services that we can provide for our own
language
then um
I mean it's not it's not urgent but some
maybe somebody will sometimes sometimes
have a good idea for you you need
for the separate evaluate yeah
um
private evaluate
it's probably not right
um
well could you write this down please
separate evaluate
I don't really like that but but private
evaluate
you know what this really is like is
you're on a web browser
and
you go into you know incognito mode or
something and you do something and in
other words it's a it's a it's a
sub-evaluation that doesn't mess up your
main state
do you see what I'm saying yes
and it also does not have access to to
meditate I mean
it's completely separate so that's why
it should be called separate evaluate or
something but it's kind of like um
separated evaluate or something I don't
know that's not quite the right word but
but um
um
yeah we can bring this up in one of TC
meetings at the end after people have
had a chance to think about it
and probably trying to get to the second
main point of this uh yeah let's get to
it okay so the second
main point is obviously that new tab in
the system preferences so without a lot
of
Grammy so this has too many tabs here
these are by the way by the way I'm just
another name disjoint evaluate it's a
bit weird
it's not quite right yet but we'll get
it yes okay all right let's go to the
second thing so these steps at the
moment they are not actually I've got
another name I've got another name I've
got another name Branch evaluate
yeah still not quite right but it's
getting there
Okay so yes
so the that new thing will
this first tab on the left there is this
list of all the kernels you have ever
touched and that can include your
favorite that can include persistent
data from your cloud account and so on
and so it's just a browser for all the
kernels that you've ever
configured
and you can edit those that will bring
up the thing that we've seen before that
editor for that individual kernel
configuration
you can duplicate what does tool mean
what a tool mean
there's a pool oh that's for wstp Server
can set up the wsdp server maintains
kernel named kernel pools and you can
choose
you might have a pool with a from a
kernel with a GPU that there's another
Pool for parallel kernels
and so on and there might be a pool for
version 13.2 currents and other
political version 17.3 kernels and so on
so you can choose which pool to
to request colorful
okay that's terminology of ws3 no no I
understand that okay so this thing of
things on the left I mean mine might be
30 things long including ones from five
years ago
is that right or is that not right yeah
I mean it keeps it keeps it persistently
until you you hit the reset button also
also it could be long but that that's
why they are the filter so I could say I
want only to see only the parallel sub
kernels or I'm on to see all usages but
I want to see on the SSH kernels or SSH
kernels so you can there are there are
these filters
and obviously it should scroll when when
the list gets long what is lwg
lightweight grid light rate yes
okay
okay so what happens if I hit go to the
parallel kernels
this one yeah
okay so this is where you specify which
ones you want to use by default
so that's your dollar default kernel so
these are the ones you specify here are
the ones that are used when you say
launch kernels without an argument and
here we could add these named sets of
kernels
okay so that is well I'm trying to get
some okay kernel configuration editor is
the Cesspool with everything in it is
that right
beside but yeah that contains that
contains everything
you can edit
and this one I mean another way would be
to have check boxes here but so that's
that's something that you need to design
this UI design whether it's
whether we should overload this but it's
probably already very crowded
and at the moment I've chosen just for
this okay hold on we're zooming out for
a second okay hold on hold on this
kernel preferences thing first thing is
it has the the inventory of all possible
kernels is that correct yes yes that's
what this is so if I have a hundred
kernels I have a bunch of different
machines I have kernels on them where
does that show up does that show it on
the left sidebar here
yeah I mean these are the kernel
configurations so you would only have
one for all the currents on that
particular machine right
so okay but I mean like like in my case
I have I don't know what I don't know
six seven machines eight machines I
don't know how many machines yeah then
you would have then you would have eight
entries with ssh in front for those
machines
okay
and I mean to me
the details of what the host name is and
all that kind of thing
I might very well want just a human name
for that yeah I mean that that is uh for
example if I edit this one this is I can
change the name
okay and so now it will that's the name
so far the name has always always been
there but so far I haven't actually used
it for anything sensible so the name at
the moment is rather pointless but uh
because I have all these different
persistence uh settings I need a way to
you know okay but so the backing of this
whole preferences thing is some
expression is that true
so like like for example in my case I
could get somebody to make me a an
appropriate
okay let's say I want let's say I ask
somebody make me one of these for Azure
okay make me a thing with my account
settings and all that kind of thing so I
can just plug it in and use as your how
do I do yeah you could I mean there is
at the moment there is no I haven't
mocked this up but uh
it should be possible to end of a cloud
ex Cloud object that contains that
information or cloud or just answer the
expression that contains their
information somebody sent it to me or
email let's say yes there should be a
way to load this yes that's good now one
of the tricky things is it might need to
interact with my keychain
to contains account information I might
want that on my keychain I can type yes
now that is relevant for the SSH kernels
and the SSH has its own key management
system
so how does that work I mean if I if
somebody sends me oh this is a remote
kernel you could use
yes now there is a way to where is it
let's see
you can specify the
the SSH key here in the kernel
configuration
okay but is that in plain text or is
that no the key the key is the key that
that's the that's the uh
that's the private key which is usually
protected by password that's a file file
on your system that contains the key
okay
to a system credential yes it uh
its own system that is usually also
connected to your keychain
so you would have to load that key just
once and it would be remembered in your
login session
automatically
okay okay
so all right let's just see to the end
of your agenda because okay so so this
is the tab that allows you to select
which kernels to use for parallelism and
this is where we could have these named
sets now this tab which is probably not
even necessary would allow you to choose
which kernels that should show up in the
notebooks kernel evaluation menu we
probably want to to list all of the ones
that are capable of being notebooks
girls I don't think so I think it's good
to have this okay yes because I mean I
mean I'm telling you I've got stupid
Cesspool stuff that's from you know 10
years ago sitting around there but I
don't necessarily want to kill it let me
give you an example okay okay you could
just turn it on and off yes yeah right I
mean that's a good point I'm going to
hang out in my
office you know in Illinois or something
I go there once a year or something like
that I want to reconfigure this because
I've got a different machine there yes
blah blah blah
okay good then the next step that just
allows you to choose this uh dollar
default local currently for remote
control already exist so obviously it
should be possible to persistently
choose wait a minute wait a minute
that's what we're calling and someone
has suggested Zab suggested partitioned
evaluate
has another name for the separate
evaluate this
or extrinsic evaluate Doug suggests that
but I think that's a little bit too
weird
um uh
but that's got to mirror you know it's
got to be basically you know and this in
these tabs they've got to be graphically
designed differently so one of them is
Kernel configuration
you know it's basically
that's I don't understand that's a
configuration editor for all kernels but
why
I see
um yes so you have your 100 different
special use case kernels and say okay
which one do you want to use by default
for local evaluate
and then you will we can select it I
know but that's just like saying which
ones do you want to use by default for
parallel evaluations yes
it should be called default kind of
because the one specifically for these
you know partitioned evaluate or
something you know what I'm saying it
should mirror the name that we're using
for that
uh well easy because it's I mean another
possibility would be down here you could
also have the default notebook kernel
specified here
this would be consistent with what we
are doing here well are you sure it's
the right thing to do I think it'd be a
better thing to do to just say parallel
kernels and then what's the default in
the parallel kernels tab front-end
kernels what's the default in the front
end kernels tab
yes rather than separately Bank
switching the defaults which doesn't
seem I mean if we're going to do that
the default should come first right
after the kernel configuration editor
okay so the parallel current step will
that already contains that default which
is as I said before this is this design
is my requirements to include in dollar
default kernels to use for parallel
Computing is that the sole function of
the parallel kernels tab I don't think
so I think it's something that yes yeah
okay but it's the thing that should give
you the map of these are the named
groups of parallel kernels yes so
because main groups is something new
right okay fine fine I understand that
but then and at the front end I agree
that default from notebook evaluator and
default should go here
okay fine and then we are left with the
default for locally valid and remote
evaluate and I'm not sure they deserve
their own tab but
maybe well I mean I think
we do have Billy in here now if you want
to discuss any of that with him uh yes
but we've kind of run out of time now
the other one is uh something new that I
haven't worked on yet but I think it
would be nice to have an overview of all
the kernels that are running
uh What uh but that's similar to the
kernel the parallel kernel status option
yes but but not only for parallel curves
but if you have local session kernels
and front-end
kernels running then it should be why
not have a kernel status dialogue that
shows all of them well that's that's I
think what what this should return yeah
I understand that but you might as well
show it in I mean like for example it
will be useful if I've got parallel
kernels running
I mean
you know there are wacky things that go
on like for example each parallel kernel
could could call its own local evaluate
and you wouldn't see that here
no there is no way I could ever right
but so this is the things attached to
the current
kernel
correct yes just like everything here
right so what I'm suggesting is that we
just have one status yeah the power
current state is to turn into a channel
right here running kernel status or
something yes that's what this is
intended to be
okay
um
uh
okay I'm gonna have to go in very very
soon so what else is that to to go
through here no I mean this is just a
detailed discussion of the various tabs
which we have already looked at
so I think we had a couple of naming
questions that we settled that we still
have to settle
and then I need to think about those
named kernel groups and then we should
hand this over to design as soon as
possible
I think so and um
uh okay now I assume that the cloud has
nothing to say about this
cloud is not involved other than as a
storage for persistent information right
because you can't run yeah
no no you can use cloud kernels as
locally as remote evaluate kernels
no I understand
at this time there is no way to run
okay there's two things that I think you
know for example from the cloud you
can't call an AWS kernel correct that is
correct yes even though that was a
project that famously was supposed to
get done like seven years ago
because you're talking about the about
the private cloud or
no I'm talking about the ability
for one two
you know say I want to run this
computation I mean you know the thing
we've been talking about for years is
I've got this computation I want to for
15 minutes I want to run it on 2 000
kernels yes now from I mean we now have
the technology thanks to Jesse's work
right so
and in the in the
in the desktop this once all of this is
in place then we have everything we need
to support that workflow
give you an idea of the uh the timing
and the amount of work involved the I'm
pretty sure that if this goes as planned
that without except for the front-end
kernels this can be put into the next
version the front-end kernels obviously
requires a lot of cooperation with the
front end because I mean I don't I think
we can I can support the current way the
front end launches local kernels but the
way it launches SSH kernels and wstp
server kernels requires quite a bit of
work because the front end will actually
have to use the system kernel to to help
with a new way of establishing the
connections
right I I really unfortunately need to
go to this other meeting but
um I think we have covered a good
collection of this I think we should you
know time to go through you know the
form function thing design
and uh
another moment too soon the stuff I've
wanted it for a long long long long time
is really lwg is that really a transport
thing are we really going to do it that
way it's an lwg lwg colon is that what
we're going to do is that a problem
it already works now that's the uh but
yes I mean we these all these these you
can just make up your own there you
don't even have to register those
yeah I understand
um right looking good okay I really need
to run but um good stuff thank you all
thanks to folks on live stream see you
all